John is in New York City to start off
this hour hey John welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave hey thank you for
taking my call
sure man what's up I yeah I love your
show
and I need your opinion regarding
student loans okay IRA our son-in-law
graduated from dental school about three
years ago and owes two hundred and
seventy thousand dollars in educational
loans he joined his father's a dental
practice and has been paying $4,000 a
month towards that loan and he'll soon
be buying the practice they currently
are living on beans and rice and are
very focused on paying off his debt my
wife and I wanted to help them by giving
them $100,000 but we're really unsure if
the right thing to do and my reason for
calling you why are you unsure what why
would you know what what what is on them
don't do this column what is under the
don't do this column my son-in-law is
very calculated I think this isn't a
surprise for him
I don't want to overstep my bounds
enabling comes to mind but in talking to
my daughter she was the word is an
overwhelmed but just the whole cost of
this whole process she wonders um you
know how they're ever going to get out
of it and and and when he gets the
practice from his father he's going to
buy that practice from his father yes he
is and where is he going to get that
money I believe he is that have worked
that out over time so he's going to owe
his father a note yes and do we have any
idea how much that is no I don't
okay well if it kind of feels weird to
me if I'm you that I'm getting ready to
give him a hundred but his own dad's
getting ready to charge him through the
nose for this practice you know like
you're trying
to get him out of the hole in his own
dad saying hey here's a shovel dig a
little deeper that feels like I'm trying
to get his dad money almost like through
him I had nothing involved in any of
those companies I know but I'm just
saying I'm just looking over here let's
say his dad's selling the practice I'll
just make up a number for 300 grand and
you give him a hundred grand towards his
student loans it's almost like you're
giving his dad money through him so I
ain't going to get little control freaky
if it's me I don't know how to do this
and I don't know what yours
relationships are and so it might not be
doable but let's say that everybody was
smiling and happy and willing to talk
about this meaning his dad you and him
and the three of you go to coffee and
say dad whatever figure you were going
to sell it to him if you'll drop that by
a hundred we'll throw a hundred at the
student loans good point because I don't
really want to just throw money at it
and then dad sells the stinking practice
for premium full retail price juniors
paying that because I kind of feel like
indirectly dad's getting my money here I
don't mind you helping them I don't
think you're enabling I really don't and
I in a bio I don't think your daughter
is going to die from this so she's
probably okay she just called daddy and
whined a little bit but but the but I
don't think it's a bad thing you I think
you've got the money right like this is
not a lot of money to you I have the
money yes I mean it's not going to
damage your retirement you know you've
got an excess of you've got an excess of
a half million to a million left after
you do this deal yes we go okay I
thought so I thought I smelled that okay
yeah I'm doing it but I'm going to kind
of try to get in everybody's business in
a kind way a little bit here just
because when I put a hundred grand on
the table I buy the right to get into
your business you know just because I
want to love you well not because I'm
being a control freak that's all Oh
if omission one thing that our previous
to us think of my wife and I think about
offering this money
our son all did approach us and did say
that the city was paying
eight percent seven or eight percent on
some of his loans and if I would lend
him the money he can pay it back at a
produce rate you know it would be four
percent so he brought the topic up yeah
well yeah and I'm not doing that you
know he just trying to urge everyone to
do that I like this kid I think he's a
go-getter he's gotten all the way
through dental school he's trying to
work his way through this he's gotten
himself into a bunch of debt I want to
limit him getting into more debt later
and I think I think your daughter
married a good guy sounds like to me
that I didn't hear anything in our
conversation about this guy that rings a
bell wrong so he just other than he's in
a up to his eyeballs and he's swimming
around trying to figure out the best
thing a young guy can figure out what to
do here so yeah I'm if I'm in your shoes
I'm doing this now you know about gift
tax and you know about unified estate
tax credit and you know you can't give
him a hundred grand without doing that
properly with your CPA and there's a way
to do it without otherwise you're gonna
get a 55 percent gift tax this is going
to cost you fifty five thousand dollars
in taxes if you do this wrong so make
sure if you're going to give away a gift
this size you know that you're doing
that properly through your estate
planning and your CPA but aside from
that that's how I would do it I would
sit down with him and Dad over coffee
and go okay dad you put in a hundred
I'll put in 100 let's get these kids on
the track here and then let them work
their way through the rest of it and I
think they can and that's that's fine
and yes yes I would do that if I were in
your shoes I would not do this if people
start bossing me around or I start to
feel like somebody's taking advantage of
the fact that I'm willing to be generous
I'm going to be wise about that but not
I just don't want to get involved in
toxicity and start throwing money in the
middle of a toxic soup that'll take you
to a bad place so anyway it doesn't make
it get better if it's toxic if it's good
and you put money in it it makes it get
better and that's where you want to go